Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher: Scene work
is interesting because in when we talk about scene
work all we really need is a character or we need
more than one character but the character needs
conflict so we want to keep our characters in as
much conflict as possible and there's a film I
always bring up to my students who and I make them
watch it over and over again because it's a Little
Miss Sunshine carries the torch of scene by scene
of hitting conflict shifting power dynamics which
is also another word for shifting status I feel
like that comes up more in TV shows and TV scripts
the shifts of status and it's so powerful that
when we see it in a movie it's pretty cool so when
I'm rewriting a scene I go over who has status in
the scene and then is there a way to play with it
so I'll do an example of a cop interrogating a a
suspect so there's a cop and he's interrogating a
there it is a cop interrogating a suspect and
the cop has high status and the suspect is in
handcuffs the suspect may even be crying and the
suspect has low status so when you're watching a
scene think about power dynamics and think about
status because that's what actors are thinking
about and that's what writers are thinking about
when they're writing and actors are thinking about
that when they're playing together but we can
shift we can shift that dynamic because in let's
say in the same scene the suspect has information
that the cop wants so then the cop realizes this
and maybe the suspect smiles and the cop slams his
fist on the table and he's upset as the suspect
is not giving him this information and all of a
sudden the suspect has higher status and the cop
is lower status the cop wants something from the
suspect needs something from the suspect and the
suspect is giving it up so when you're watching
films keep an eye out on the on the status and
power dynamics and watch how the protagonists can
go in and out of high status and low status in
scenes like in here's the example of Little Miss
Sunshine when we're introduced to Richard. Richard
is Richard is talking about his life coaching
his I forget what it's like five principles
for being the amazing man you are meant to be he's
commanding the stage as he's eyeing the crowd and
going over his presentation and then the camera
turns around and it shows us how many people are
in the audience and there's like maybe 10 and he
gets a tepid applause so the director the director
gave us a power dynamic shift we thought we were
seeing a very high status person almost talking
to a stadium of people and then we realize he's
low status and it's practically a conference room
and no one really cares what he's saying it's a
lot of fun and that's and that and that's when
Richard goes back down to low status refuse to
lose that's what it is right, the nine concepts.
Film Courage: Speaking of Little Miss Sunshine of
all characters in the film who has
the biggest sort of status shift?
Tony: Well our the the character with that has
the most arc is Richard the dad because and when
we look at little miss shine Richard is the
protagonist because he's the one that needs
to take the journey and to learn so when we get
to act three he has to Showdown with himself to
finally get out of this facade that he's creating
as a guy with a master plan and everyone needs to
succeed and he makes a fool of himself at the end
with his daughter which just is that scene always
really gives me chills when I watch it but but his
his he's trying to get high status the whole time
when he when he gets into his low status and kind
of saves his daughter from having embarrassment
alone that's when he has challenged himself and he
has won because he's be he's lost his status but
he's become the father he's supposed to be for
the family and the whole family comes together
when Dad kind of realizes that wait a second
I need to save my daughter that's beautiful.
Film Courage: And just real quick which character
has the least arc in Little Miss Sunshine?
Tony: Tony Colette's character the wife really has
it she feels like a placeholder and I don't know
if in early rewrites if she had an arc because a
lot of these characters have arcs there's Dwayne
who has a oh that yeah that's a great ensemble
photo the father has an arc I mean he's a junkie
and then he dies sure and I know and Little Miss
and the the young girl who plays Little Miss Sun
little the little going to the beauty contest she
doesn't have much of an arc either she's kind of
like a placeholder so there's there's a lot of
fun happening I think between Dwayne and the
brother through a lot of the film and that might
be they may be hitting the philosophical points
of what the writer was intending to kind of give
the moral of the story throughout I'm just coming
off a memory I haven't watched it in about a year
because that's my first quarter students we have
to watch it over and over and over again and it's
so worth it yeah I want to go back to watch it
it's been a while thank you I want to see it
what are storytelling cheats and and which are
some that are fun to use storytelling cheats
I'm glad you asked because I have some notes
about okay if you want to like feeling sympathy
for for a character some ways to get right to
feeling sympathetic Blake Snyder wrote the book
Save The Cat so there so there's that's a way to
get sympathy immediately immediately save a
cat here's another example let's say a mom's
just trying to clean the house before her in-laws
arrive have her step on a Lego have her have her
step on like a tack or a nail when we when we when
we do something with the palm of the hand when we
cut the palm of the hand or the bottom of the
foot as we're watching it we've all experienced
that pain especially on the foot the bottom of
the foot hurts so bad right and it immediately
gives us an emotional response where we're like
we've been there we've done that so that's an
element to add to a scene if we look at Minority
Report in a Minority Report everyone is scanned
by their eyeballs and so when Tom Cruise is on the
run and he's wanted for the future murder he has
to get rid of his eyeballs it it's so I mean it
me just that idea alone brings massive conflict
and then and so think about what you can do with
the eyeballs can you touch the eye can you poke
the eye what I through that whole operation scene
of Minority Report with Tom Cruise it we're we're
like losing our minds sure and then if we go back
to Little Miss Sunshine it's the there's a lovely
thing that the writer does which is he gives
Dwayne the vow is silence Dwayne didn't have
to have that vow I don't know what draft of the
script where the writer went what because the
writer of the script in early drafts could have
just had Dwayne upset and mad at his parents
and it would have been fine but he has a vow of
silence and it escalates his tragedy so when he
finds out he's collar blind and he can't become an
pilot I think he wants to be a pilot and you can't
be a pilot when you call her blind when the that
plot Point happens that's the first time he speaks
and when he speaks after he hasn't been speaking
of throughout the whole film we pay immediate
attention so it's like it's symbolic on so many
level levels and the other thing about Little Miss
Sunshine is the VW van situation just make make
make the VW ban only start in second gear what
what a fantastic story device because it makes
it it makes the family push the van and they all
have to jump in the van so there's danger involved
there's the family just being disgusted they have
to do this and and it's a device that brings us
to the very end of the film it's a device because
they hate working together when this happens
it's drudgery through the film when they've
come together in the last scene as they push
the van through the parking lot they're they're
pushing the van as a family all of a sudden we
see them as they they've all kind of been reborn
into becoming a family and so watching them push
the van is a whole new experience for us and them.